hi it's Mike BOS from orderflows and
I've spent decades trading orderflow
I've taught other Traders and designed
software tools that turned ordinary
Traders into successful orderflow
Traders but here's the truth the
Market's tougher now than ever old
tricks don't cut it you need an edge
that works today that's why I've put
everything I know into a game-changing
course called the footprints and focus
orderflow trading course now unlike
other trading courses that talk about
the basics of orderflow and the
footprint chart this is a deep dive into
to footprint charts the Ultimate Weapon
that reveals the Market's every step
from spotting institutional moves to
scalping ticks in seconds this course
hands you the knowledge to trade
successfully there's eight modules
packed with battle tested strategies
straight from my playbook so in module
one you'll uncover the role of order
flow how to spot the big players
Footprints like massive volume clusters
or Delta spikes and trade alongside
their strength or fade their traps then
in module two clean charts versus chop
charts you'll learn to ditch the noise
and trade only the smoothest most
tradable Trends saving you time and cash
in module 3 order flow and different
market conditions shows you how to adapt
whether the Market's a volatile storm a
thin ghost town or a trending gold mine
next in module four Delta distribution
footprint techniques you're going to
dive into high Delta zones your support
and breakout hotspots turning order flow
into setups in module 5 orderflow SC
scalping with footprint charts we're
going to show you how to scalp for quick
trades with footprint aggression or
micro reversal signals then in module 6
Advanced footprint techniques we're
going to introduce you to brand new
never shared orderflow trade setups in
module 7 exit techniques going to teach
you how to use Smart stops trailing
exits and emergency exits all powered by
footprint precision and finally in
module 8 putting it all together your
pre-trade checklist going to tie
everything you have learned into a
process so you'll know exactly when to
trade and when to walk away so Traders
have paid me thousands for one-on-one
coaching to master orderflow footprint
reading but I wanted to reach more of
you you know serious Traders ready to
step up that's why I've packed
Footprints in focus with everything you
know eight modules hours of videos show
you some trade setups and examples for
just a fraction of that cost with
Footprints and focus you're not just
learning you're improving there's no
fluff no outdated n sense just the raw
unfiltered truth of orderflow trading
but here's the catch this isn't for
everyone if you're not ready to put in
the work this isn't your course but if
you're serious if you're ready to trade
smarter sharper and Bolder then this is
your opportunity so click the link below
to get started with Footprints and focus
the orderflow trading course and I'll
see you guys on the inside